in honor of steve spurrier college
coaches who were very good who came to
the nfl and then were not very good
before we get to that though one of my
favorite steve spurrier quotes
when he was new to the nfl
and jim hasland at the time was the
coach of the saints they were getting
ready to play
and spurrier said i saw a story where
jim hasla comes in at 4 30 in the
morning that's not doing him much good
haslam wanted to beat him up uh so i
can't remember what happened when they
finally played but chances are the the
saints uh handled the washington
football team at the time all right
first choice to you shireen great
college coach that flamed out at the nfl
level
well you got to stop start with bobby
petrino right that was a colossal
failure in 2007 he didn't even make it
through a whole season you talk about
michael vick got arrested in the dog
fighting ring uh that year never played
for him started three and ten and then
he said see i'm out of here i'm headed
back to arkansas and if you remember
mike and i had forgotten about this
until i started in my research today
remember how he informed the players he
put that laminated
uh four senate statement in each one of
them's lockers and that's how he told
falcons players that he was leaving
and work done who never said a bad word
about anyone yeah
he wanted to beat up bobby petrino the
way that petrino left and uh it it it
really it really was a low point for
that franchise after the mike vic fiasco
petrino one and done walks away with
games left and then the falcons next
year they turned it around they went to
the playoffs with matt ryan as a rookie
quarterback by the way saints
washington
october 13 2002 after spurrier said what
he said 43 saints 27 washington so take
that coach spear and then berta beat him
again the next year so spurrier was owen
two against the saints all right first
of all he's gotta be nick saban i i'm
not gonna be the alabama coach two years
in miami he was miserable and the fact
that he's been such a great college
coach makes his stint with the nfl
so more glaring for the fiasco that it
was relative to what he's accomplished
in college so without question nick's
saving greatest college coach of all
time
not the greatest professional coach of
all time not by a long shot
and there's another one mike who was a
great college coach and was a colossal
failure in the nfl and that's lou holtz
he was horrible he had choices from
three teams and he selected the jets
because he said there aren't many teams
in the nfl better than jets guess what
the 1976 jets went 3-10 they averaged 12
points a game 12 points yes 12. they
allowed 27.2 he decides he's going to
run the veer offense with joe namath and
bad knees bad decision and oh by the way
the best story about that team during
the preseason after they won a game he
hands each player
a words to a jets fight song who knew
they had a fight song and said we're
going to learn to sing this after every
win so there's a thought that maybe the
players lost on purpose so they didn't
have to sing the fights on oh god i
didn't know about that one but i i
definitely remember lou holtz as the
coach of the jets unfortunately i
remember as the coach at notre dame when
they beat west virginia for the national
championship in 1988. next one for me
i'm torn here
i'm torn but you know what all things
considered and in light of the hype that
he entered the nfl with and how he was
going to revolutionize the game i got to
go chip kelly i gotta go chip kelly i
know he went to the playoffs his first
year with the eagles but it was all
downhill from there fired after three
seasons then one and done in san
francisco and then done and done forever
in the nfl with all that and i remember
people in the media were acting like
this is vince lombardi reincarnated
coming to the nfl and i remember
thinking what wait because they have
individualized smoothies what are you
what what what is it that chip kelly has
discovered out in oregon that somehow is
going to revolutionize professional
football and i'm kind of glad that it
didn't because i was sick of hearing
about it and yes he failed shireen
yeah he did and i'm going to stick with
that same state mike and i'm going to go
it was a tough call but i'm gonna go
with mike riley from oregon state he was
eight and fourteen in two seasons at
oregon state comes out chargers hired
him why no idea ryan leaves second
season they went eight and eight and
ninety nine one in fifteen and two
thousand surprised he didn't get fired
after that season and then 5 and 11 in
2001 and he was history went back to the
college ranks and had a good career
again at oregon state
uh the last one for me
uh
and and you know
there always is a fine line between
thinking outside the box and
and just you know nutty and it was greg
sciano when he was plucked by the
buccaneers from rutgers at a time when
no one was talking about greg giano as
being an nfl coach and again it's
another one of those and and i don't i
don't know
i i i don't know are we wired to be
glass half full or if we're going to be
wrong would we rather be wrong by
praising someone than by saying this
isn't going to work but i remember there
was all this over-the-top praise for
what shiana was going to do
and i'm everything and yeah we'll see
we'll see and the players didn't take to
him and it all fell apart quickly and
that was that for greg ciano as an nfl
head coach didn't last long and he's not
coming back sharina
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports